Hi!
My name is Christian and I am the Product
Manager for Native Client, a technology that
allows you to run native code in the browser
in a safe way.
In developer events, I am often asked in what
ways Native Client can help developers.
In this video, I am going to present the most
common use cases where our team thinks Native
Client can make a huge difference.
Many developers have large code bases written
in C or C++ and want to use this code to build
web applications.
So, rewriting everything in JavaScript would
take a long time.
With Native Client it is fairly easy to port
your existing code to the web platform.
For example one engineer working at Spacetime
Studios ported Star Legends - an MMO with
half a million lines of code in just 2 weeks!
There are also many cases where an application
has significant performance requirements.
While we’ve seen amazing improvements in
JavaScript performance the last couple of
years, some applications need all the performance
they can get.
Native Client runs native code, so you can
create these performance intensive applications
for the web.
If you’ve developed a desktop app that you
want to make portable across operating systems,
we believe Native Client can help you out,
especially if your app performs heavy computation
like many games, photo editing and video editing
apps.
With Native Client you only have to maintain
one code base but your app can run on Windows,
Mac, Linux, and Chrome OS.
Finally, we understand that for some web apps
you may prefer to write parts of them in languages
other than JavaScript.
Native Client currently has the tools that
allow you to write web applications that run
C and C++ code in the browser.
Mono also works on Native Client, so you can
run the .NET family of languages, such as
C#.
And in the future we’ll work to support
even more languages.
These are the most common use cases where
we believe Native Client can be helpful for
developers.
If you are interested in learning more, check
out our website at gonacl.com